[Music]
hi folks how's it goin congratulations
it's Friday you made it ah it's been a
really fun couple of days I know it's
been fun for me getting to talk to a lot
of customers see a lot of product
announcements a lot of demos a lot of
fantastic conversations and I'm really
excited today to come talk about App
Engine we've got a lot of good stuff
going on here we're going to be going
through a couple of cool things you can
do with App Engine really this is a
product that's been around for 10 years
now which in the cloud space is a really
really long time and from when it first
came out to where we are now a lot of
things have happened the cloud has
changed technology has changed the kinds
of applications that we need to build
for our customers have fundamentally
changed and really what today about is
digging in and understanding how App
Engine has kind of changed with the
times can I get a great platform for
helping build your applications so let's
have a little bit of fun before we get
into fun a little bit about myself my
name is Justin Beckwith I'm a product
manager at Google primarily these days
actually working on App Engine so this
is kind of a you know for the last few
years this has been my baby it's very
exciting if you want to get in touch
with me my twitter information is up
there also my github handle all of the
demos that we're going to see this today
and actually a lot of the technology
that we're gonna see today it's all open
source and this is all part of one of
the things that we're trying to do which
is get more and more openness more into
the open source community and everything
you're going to see here large parts of
it all open source so before we dig
right in just a little bit before we go
build demos on App Engine and learn a
bunch of cool stuff what is what is App
Engine at the end of the day it's a very
simple way to take your code give it to
us and run it on top of Google's
infrastructure at scale so this so
really the fundamental thing that we
want you to walk away with is you bring
your code and we handle running it on
Google's infrastructure and when you're
running it on Google's infrastructure
what you're really doing is running
inside of a data center that's been
proven out for almost the last 20 years
the same technology that's been built
for Google Search Maps Gmail all these
things that we rely on day in and day
out we've proven infrastructure has
gotten the job done at Google and proven
methods for getting it done and we think
we want to make
easy for you to do the same thing with a
pension so what would you build on top
of App Engine well there are a couple of
sweet spots and we've seen that you know
several compute offerings today and
we're going to get into those in a
little bit but really there's a sweet
spot for App Engine is web applications
and api's so if you're building a user
facing website via no js' Ruby PHP you
know any of your traditional web
languages it's really a great
destination because you can just build
it deploy it and run it without having
to think about the obser scale it's also
become a really popular back-end for
mobile applications there's some pretty
canonical examples out there folks like
snapchat other gaming companies that are
built on top of us it's really easy to
scale up very very quickly on App Engine
and it's easy to get up and running very
fast so it's been a popular choice for
mobile backends with that really comes
just also HTTP api's even if it's not a
traditional mobile backend a lot of us
our applications are powered by API and
in App Engine integrates really nicely
with cloud endpoints another product
that we announced the v2 of recently
which makes easy to do things like
metering billing logging authentication
all sitting on top of your API and cloud
functions and App Engine make a really
nice fit together to go build those
kinds of things and then lastly it's a
great fit for line of business
applications we're working with a lot of
enterprises today that have a ton of
internal sites that they need to build
build quickly maintain and do it with a
small staff that they don't want to have
to build up expertise in five different
deployment systems an app engine has
been a great fit for that as a matter of
fact it's running the majority of a lot
of our internal apps that we have at
Google the user facing web applications
we use for a lot of our payroll systems
for our learning management systems all
this stuff at Google is actually
increasingly built on top of App Engine
and we think it's great for other
companies to do that as well so where
does App Engine fit into kind of the
broader context of compute you know
we've heard a lot of announcements we
saw the cloud functions announcement we
have committed use discounts on virtual
machines we've heard containers
containers containers and kubernetes
over and over again where does App
Engine kind of fit into this and when is
it a good choice to use so we'll start
at the bottom of the pyramid when we
think about virtual machines and we
think about compute engine really what
you're running is infrastructure so if
you're an organization that's picking up
you're moving something a bunch of
applications were built on traditional
virtual machines and you want to pick
that up and find a path to the cloud
usually this is the easiest first step
you can take to get into the cloud if
you want to think about infrastructure
you wanna think about VMs you want to
think about networks then this is a good
fit one level up in that level of in
that level of abstraction you're going
to have containers you're an
organization that's already familiar
with docker and you want to run fleet of
docker containers efficiently across the
fleet of machines kubernetes is a
fantastic option now the next step up
when you get to App Engine this is where
we start thinking less about
infrastructure and we start specifically
thinking about serverless style
architectures you want to hand us our
code and ask Google to figure out the
most efficient and cost-effective way to
go run that code for you and really
that's what App Engine does again web
applications and api's you give us the
code we run it and then at the top if
you have a system where you want to
respond to very specific events think
web hooks or every time a file is
written to a GCS bucket you want to have
a little bit of code that reacts to that
that's where cloud functions becomes a
perfect bit instead of thinking at the
application or service level you're now
thinking at the function and event
abstraction so it's just kind of the
examples of various levels of compute we
have and where I think your applications
can fit in so with that you know there's
a lot of talking let's get into it this
is seven or eight tricks I'm going to be
honest until last night I didn't have
the eighth trick working so I wasn't
sure if I was going to have eight but
we'll see at the end if it worked out so
trick number one you can go from your
code to production in a single command
that command is g-cloud app deploy now
this is part of the cloud SDK and this
might be something that we take for
granted especially if you've been in App
Engine user for a long time it's been
out there but when you think about that
what I would normally go through the
deployment I could deploy to an
individual virtual machine I could take
these files and upload the one VM but
what happens when my application gets
popular it needs to scale-up
what happens when maybe there's trouble
in the zone where I've deployed my
virtual machine what happens when you
know something changes with the there's
a problem with the underlying disk a lot
of things can go wrong when we run on
one instance and if we're just to point
to a single machine we're putting our
application and potentially our business
at risk and we need to think about a lot
of these problems so you create an
ointment in App Engine
we do a couple of things I'm going to
take your code we're going to upload it
to Google Cloud Storage we're going to
take that and you don't need to
understand anything about docker to use
App Engine but under the hood what we're
actually doing is we're building your
code along with our runtimes that we
build into a container and then that
container gets pushed to Google
container registry and now it's
available for all of your App Engine
applications we've set up a Google cloud
load balancer which this is new we're
now using the same cloud load balancer
across all of Google's infrastructure is
coming in the same path and then we're
going to take your application and we
run it in three availability zones now
the reason that we do this is that there
may be trouble in an individual zone at
any point you know generally this stuff
is very stable but sometimes things in
individual zones happen so what we do is
automatically out-of-the-box configure
App Engine to deploy to three different
availability zones so that even if we do
have a problem your application is going
to automatically rebalance and keep
serving to your customers and then
within each of those zones they all
independently autoscale so is the use of
your application grows and as traffic
increases and as that use contracts
again we're going to automatically
provision and release new instances to
serve your applications so along the way
so we just talk mainly about application
instances and the auto scalars they're a
bunch of other things that we're setting
up out of the box stuff that when you
deploy an app to that individual VM you
have to think about at one point or
another you have to think about logging
how are you capturing your logs where
are you sending those logs is that log
system going to scale can you query
through it efficiently when you need to
we when you think about auto scaling
what do you happen when you get popular
traffic goes up traffic comes back down
load balancing monitoring health
checking configuring SSL these are all
additional things that when you go to
set up a site or a deployment on your
own you've to internalize me of to think
about instead of building your
application or focusing on your business
and they're all things we aim to do with
App Engine so one of the new things that
we have that we've had now for a couple
actually for a couple of months we've
been working on or a couple years is the
App Engine flexible environment so
originally App Engine was available in
go or Python Java and PHP and we've now
expanded that to include nodejs Ruby and
the big announcement yesterday of course
is a dotnet going beta on App Engine as
well
you can even bring your own container
and this is something we're going to get
a chance to look at in a little bit one
of the big changes we're able to
announce yesterday is all these services
that you can run your own docker
container node Ruby you can do all of
this with a 99.995% SLA and that's
something that we're able to offer
because as of yesterday the App Engine
flexible environment is GA it's ok you
can clap I need this
thank you so the first trick with
g-cloud app deploy getting 99.95% SLA
with a single command and not having to
think about it let's dig in a little bit
to the second trip trick this is one of
my favorite ones with App Engine I can
split traffic between multiple versions
of my application so why is this
important
think about that deployment we just
created so we pushed our code we got it
out there we have a multi multi zonal
release we've got many instances it's
going great but now I'm ready to push a
new version well how do I know that my
new version doesn't have a bug how do I
know that isn't going to bring my app
crashing down when I do it what I want
to do is I want to deploy a second
version of my application I want to
verify it out-of-band
both with tests and I want to go do
manual checks and then slowly over time
I'm going to take just a little bit of
traffic and start sending it to that new
set of instances I want to make sure
that it can scale up the way I expected
to I want to make sure the things don't
come crashing down I want to monitor air
and then only one I'm ready and only one
I'm sure that this new deployment is
good I want to take transition 100% of
my traffic over to the new version and
then eventually turn down the old one
and what this is called is a no downtime
upgrade and it's something that's very
difficult to get read on your own but
one of the things with App Engine we
make very simple use g-cloud app deploy
you set a traffic split however you'd
like to set it verify and then and then
go to 100% and it's really easy to set
up so another reason that you might want
to go off and use our traffic splitting
feature is if you want to do something
like a bee testing so let's imagine that
I have I have an application out there
I'm an online grocer and I'm selling
fruit to people and I'm trying to decide
which background image is going to cause
my customers to come into my site and
buy more fruit you know what do they
think is more delicious let's look at
some salivating and buying things on my
site is it apples is it cherries
the lemons or is it the deliciously
pungent durian you know I don't know I
don't know what's going to go ahead and
get them hungry
so let's actually this demo time let's
figure out how we can actually go build
something like this on top of App Engine
so what I've got here is I have a site
that I've created on App Engine it's got
a single service this single service has
four different versions of my
application each ones that I've deployed
with the g-cloud app deploy command you
can see I've got the cherry version the
Apple version during in lemon
so if I click on Sherri every time I do
that we get a cherry looks pretty good
makes me a little hungry it is lunchtime
I can click on Apple and I'm going to
get my apples and you get the point I
can click on these individually and any
one at a time I can verify is going to
give me the fruit that it's named after
but right now all of my customers are
getting cherry so every time they come
the sites are going to get cherry how do
I enable a traffic split to test out my
hypothesis you know I'm going to go with
the idea that I think Apple is a better
fit I can select all the versions of my
running application right now I can
choose split traffic and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to go ahead and say
Apple is going to get 33% lemon is going
to get 33% and during in we're going to
put that at 1% because we're still
testing I am still unsure if the durian
is a good choice or not and I'm going to
go ahead and save this so while this is
saving the next thing that we're going
to do is we're going to click on
services and we're actually going to
take a look at how this worked so I have
a single service right now one service
many versions under it and I'm going to
go ahead and launch this page and it
looks like ok the first time I got lemon
the second time I got cherry and then
Apple and so on and so forth
so what we can actually do is the way
I've set up the site is I want to be
able to track this you know maybe you
don't believe that we're actually doing
that traffic so it exactly right so
let's go here and I'm going to go over
to a dashboard that's actually tracking
all of the hits on this page and I see
somebody hitting Apple I don't know if
anyone was able actually to see that URL
or not and so this is the point in the
talk where I want everybody on usually
speakers don't like it when you're on
your phones or laptop I'm looking at you
guys with the laptop it wasn't actually
you go ahead and get them out get out
your phone get out your laptop and I
want everyone to
try this out and we're going to watch it
in real-time and see what happens so I
want everyone to go to fruit App Engine
dot IO so fruit App Engine dot IO and
let's see we're watching people hit
these pages coming in real-time it looks
like right now
apples are out to a lead cherries are
catching up when you keep doing this
until that 1% person manages up who got
the durian oh come on someone has to
admit to it somebody got the dirty end
it was you was it come on up come up on
stage you're the big winner I can't
believe it with you that actually won
the tourney and that's amazing what I
have for you sir is an actual durian
that I got in Chinatown this morning so
um please do not cut that here take that
home okay that was a lot heavier than I
expected it to be I'm not gonna lie
enterprise scenarios here folks that's
what we're focusing on this week all
right so that's one of the ways that we
can use traffic splitting to both do
safe upgrades and to make sure that we
have the best version of our site for
a/b testing by the way all those images
Creative Commons thank you for the very
nice people who made them they were
beautiful so that was trick number 2
with traffic splitting let's take a look
at trick number 3 and this is a big one
as of this week you can now run dotnet
core applications on App Engine and
that's because asp.net on App Engine
yesterday went beta so what that means
is that we have a dotnet core runtime
we've got a full list of tutorials
samples the same runtime you can use on
App Engine you can actually pick up and
use it on container engine and run it
there as well inside of the Linux VM all
the client libraries so the things that
you use to access services like spanner
the cloud vision API datastore all these
services and api's we have out there are
all available via NuGet packages on
dotnet and finally some tooling all this
is available you can learn about it on
cloud.google.com slash dotnet
got all of that getting started
documentation the runtimes the client
libraries the docks all of the stuff
that we're putting out there it's all on
github so you can actually go to github
comm slash a Google cloud platform
search for dotnet and you're going to
find all the source code that we use to
go build all of this stuff and of course
the parts I want to take a little bit of
time and look at that I think is the
most interesting is the integration
directly into Visual Studio so let's
let's take a look and try that out
alright so over here I'm running Visual
Studio this is a I believe it's 2015 and
I've got a hello we're a hello world
asp.net project up and running so I'm
going to go ahead and alt tab over to my
web browser you can see it's running on
localhost and this is your traditional
for those of you who have done asp.net
you're probably used to staring at the
screen it's the traditional file new
project color world template what you
can do is of now is if you go if I
wanted to flip say I'm ready to deploy
to App Engine I can go to my project
file I can right click on that and we
make a couple new options but the one
that we're going to try is publish hello
GCP to Google Cloud now at this point
we're going to give you the option we're
actually gonna let you choose you want
to App Engine flexible environment you
want to deploy to a container engine and
we're also going to be rolling out
support for doing this on compute engine
soon as well and you can just pick one
of these wherever you want to deploy
click the button tell us what you want
to name the version we automatically
provision one for you we're going to
automatically promote so that this goes
straight to prod and when it's done I
want to go ahead and open the website
and show me the site so as this is going
off right now we're going to do the
build it's going to kick off the
deployment process and while that
happens I want to take a look at a
couple of other things so now under
tools we also have this Google Cloud
tools and we have the cloud Explorer and
the account manager let's check out the
account Explorer this is kind of my
favorite part from within inside of
Visual Studio without having to go to
the Google developer kondakov developer
console I can get a list of all my App
Engine applications each version that's
out there running you can see I already
deployed this version earlier today I
can see all of my Google compute engine
virtual machines and I have options to
interact with those and set settings on
them I have all my cloud storage buckets
and all my Google Cloud sequel instances
all right here inside a visual studio if
you're a dotnet developer we think this
is something you're really going to love
so while we're waiting for this to
deploy you can say already have a
version deployed out here let's go ahead
and check it out running on Google Cloud
so I can right click and say open the
running service and there we have it
ASP net on App Engine alright so trick
number three was running dotnet on App
Engine let's get in to trick number four
trick number four is I can customize my
operating system packages now what does
this mean and why is it is important
traditionally with platforms of service
one of the walls that we've run into is
that you'll get started you deploy your
hello world your hello asp.net web
application you get up to a certain
point and you hit a wall there's a
library you need there's a language you
want to use there's some part of the
system that you need to go beyond where
if you're on a virtual machine you could
do it but because you're in a platform
as a service offering you get stuck well
we don't think you should have to get
stuck when that happens so what we want
to do is give you the ability to bring
in any operating system package in your
Linux virtual machine that you want to
bring in and so as a way to show this
off what I want to do is talk about
there's this application that I wanted
to go build I wanted to send everybody
home with something as it would turn out
that would have been a lot of durian
this I'd have chosen that so instead I
want to send you all home with a Twitter
card this is a card you can make on your
own it's got the next branding take a
picture and you can go ahead and put
that on Twitter if you'd like to so
let's see what this looks like let's
actually go ahead and give it a try so
I'm going to go ahead to App Engine
thought i/o and what this is going to do
is it's going to use the webcam inside
on on the web page I'm going to give a
smile alright and this is going to go
take they sent my picture to App Engine
use a couple of custom tools generate
this card and then when I'm read ready I
can go tweet it out so pretty cool so
how would I go and build something like
this how do I do the image manipulation
this is a very classic wall when you're
running up on building one of these apps
the way that I was able to do it on my
macbook is I just ran brew install image
magic you know done it was amazing it
works on my machine ship it and then I
went a little further and I figured out
actually I want graphics magic you know
this sits on top of image magic okay so
now I'm Bill
up a lot of libraries well it worked
locally but how do I get that on to how
do I get that on to App Engine and this
is where docker comes to the rescue and
let's actually check it out and see how
we would go build that so here is my
local local version of web application
this happens to be in node.js by the way
and but you could run it in whatever
language you'd like to and if you look
down I'm going to go find the spot where
I'm grabbing the image that gets posted
to my site so it's posting to the send
pick endpoint and then I'm going to save
the file locally and then I'm going to
go use the graphics magic NPM module
which has a dependency on that
underlying binary being installed inside
of my container so how do I do this
well what I'm what I'm going to do right
now is go out to the command line and
I'm going to go ahead into my photobooth
application you can see all of our files
here and what I want to do is I want to
grab the docker file that App Engine is
using under the hood to build my system
right now the only thing that I've had
to tell App Engine is here's an app dot
yeah mol please use nodejs for me when i
want to control the docker file so I can
do now is I can say G cloud beta app gen
config - - custom we're going to tell it
to update my app yeah mol and now when I
go back over here I'm going to get a
couple of new files I'm going to get
this docker file which is a file that I
didn't have before and it really
explains how we're going to build your
application I'm going to use the base
node J s image again open source on
github and we're going to go ahead and
install our dependencies I happen to use
yarn if you're no js' person then you
know it's kind of the hipster thing to
do now so what we need to do now is we
need to add the part of code that's
going to install our client libraries so
let's give this a shot so what I'm going
to say is run apt-get install - why or
oh and let's mess it up apt-get update
update and then apt-get install
- why - queue image magic and graphics
magic save and that's it when you take
in g-cloud app deploy this because
there's this docker file in my current
working directory it's going to take
that as a cue and instead of using the
the container that
we were going to pop out it's going to
use the base container and add our stuff
on top of it and then if I want to try
this out locally I don't need really
even need anything quite like a local
emulator I can actually just use the
standard docker tool chain to test this
out and know that it's going to work so
I can go off and do my docker build
Dashti my app and I'm going to end up
with a container that has everything I
need at which point I can go ahead and
dock or run it when I'm ready to go to
production again g-cloud app deploy and
it's going to be off to the off to the
races
so again we were able to just use
g-cloud app deploy
we're able to build our own docker
container all we had to do is add a
little bit of logic to install image
magic and graphics magic and again this
is where the times everybody get out
your phone or your laptop or whatever
you can go to card app engine do and
actually tweet out the card that you're
generating from this and and I'm going
to go ahead and do it as well I didn't I
didn't actually tweet out the last one
so let's do that or here I'll actually
tweet this out
so there we go sweet make a good face
make it look happy people all right
so trick number four we were able to
customize the operating system packages
trick number five we're actually going
to take and we're going to make our app
a little bit better so you look at the
application that I just ran it was
really a single App Engine service
there's a bit of a monolith right
we had one code base it was responsible
for accepting the uploads it was running
image processing it was generating new
images writing things to GCS it was
sending out links you know this is one
service that was doing a lot and you
have to wonder you know over time what's
going to happen when I scale up you know
what if my web process needs fewer
resources than the parts that's doing
image manipulation which is most likely
the case right you know is my
application can be scaling as
efficiently as it could be what happens
when I'm ready to deploy I've introduced
more risk every part of my application
is all bound in one thing and I can't
separate it out so instead of just
having one services having problems and
deploying one set of changes I have to
bring the whole thing up and put it all
out at the same time so the next thing
that you can trick you can use on App
Engine is building apps that use micro
service style architectures
so the way this works is on App Engine
every time a g-cloud app deploy I can
choose to build another service and I
can keep adding more and more of these
to construct my application these
services can talk to each other directly
through HTTP or they can use a worker
cue system in my case what I did is I
took the front end I separated it out
into a front end process it's only
responsible for serving web traffic and
accepting uploads of the image I haven't
created a back-end service with
different with a different autoscaler in
its own set of instances that are
responsible for taking taking images
running it through graphics magic and
then sending out the link so they get
rendered in the page and then I
connected to using a worker cue pattern
and I'm using Google cloud pub/sub so by
doing this what I'm able to do is
independently scale the front end of my
application from the back end of my
application making sure that I'm only
using resources that I need and reducing
the amount of risk I have when I roll
out new changes so to do this we saw
that file a PMO which essentially
described how what how I want App Engine
to interpret the code that we're sending
it and what I had to tell it was the one
time is node the environment is the App
Engine flexible environment and the name
of my service is the front end service
and I had one of these for the back end
as well and then when you're ready all
you do is g-cloud app deploy and you can
run many of these within the same
project using the same underlying
resources but you know in this example I
use node because at this stage you know
JavaScript is the language I'm the most
comfortable with what if you don't want
to use node for your back-end what if
it's a different team building the
backend and the front-end what if you
want to use Perl well that happens
sometimes sometimes you have an old
piece of code laying around or you have
that guy on your team or that girl on
your team who just needs to do it in
Perl and on App Engine this is another
one of those walls of paths that you
would run into but not anymore so the
next trick that you can do on App Engine
number five with micro-service file
architectures number six is bring your
own language to the platform yes even
perl so let's try it let's do it all
right I'm going to go over here I'm
gonna get out of my photobooth
application and I'm going to go into
some demo Perl code
that I wrote let's take a look at that
alright so here I have a very simple
purl based web application it's you it's
a purl ugly purl 5 it's using a web
framework called mojolicious
which is fun to say and it's essentially
just a very simple web app it has a
single handler that's going off on the
root of the web application and it's
going to render a template named index
that I give it and over here my
templates directory I have you know
template HTML DP and it just says
welcome to purl along with fancy green
background color and then to make that
work on App Engine I really only needed
to add two files so one is I had to add
this app DML file which we've already
talked about this describes how the app
engine tells App Engine how to run the
app we say it's a custom runtime don't
use no js' don't use Ruby I'm going to
tell you how to go run this application
we have the environment and then I'm
deploying multiple of these services
within one app because we're actually a
try a few otherwise is and then the way
that we do a custom runtime is by
providing our own docker file the exact
same way that we were able to customize
node we can use that to bring our own
language and so in this case instead of
using the built-in app engine base image
in docker I'm just going to use the
latest version of the Perl base image
that's out on docker hub I'm going to
install some dependencies I'm going to
use pearls package management system to
go install the mojolicious library I'm
going to tell it to listen on port 8080
this is a bit of a magic port on App
Engine that says where your application
is supposed to serve add the source
files play around with permissions and
then finally run the main Perl process
and that's it I can take this run
g-cloud app deploy and have a live
version of Perl running on my app but
let's try it out let's see what actually
happens so it deployed this like most of
these earlier today and I'm going to go
ahead and do a g-cloud app services list
give you a little preview maybe of
things that are to come we can see one
of them here is the perl service and
just to see that's running out on App
Engine I can do g-cloud app browse - -
service pearl this is a little
convenience command that's going to go
ahead and open it in the browser
so here we have Perl on App Engine
[Applause]
so pearl is fun but let's say add a
little bit more of a an Earthbound
scenario here you know I'm not dealing
with a legacy system let's say that
you're an iOS developer and you spend
all of these years building up expertise
in iOS applications tons of years
getting used to force objective-c and
now you've Deauville you know headfirst
into Swift and you want to be able to
take advantage of all this experience
that you have building Swift
applications on the client for the
iPhone and use that in building your
back-end web applications well on App
Engine you can actually do that so I'm
going to try out now is I have a demo
with a swift Webb's application again
we're going to run code take a little
bit of a lap around the source code and
see how it works out
all right so in my sources I have Maine
dot Swift and this is using the totora
web framework on top of Swift I'm going
to build a new router object create a
route for my health checks and then add
the HTTP server telling it to listen on
port 8080 not a whole lot going on here
very simple app all right so if we look
at the swift file we can see the
dependencies that we're bringing in and
we're using the cateura web framework
similar to how we were using mojolicious
on Perl or Express on node or rails on
Ruby same concept and then inside of my
docker file even simpler this time I'm
able to take and just from the base
image that's out there for Swift add my
source code do a swift build tell it how
to run and we're done we're running
Swift inside of docker on our machine
let's go ahead and try it out and see
what it looks like
so g-cloud app services list we did
above this time when I do G cloud out
browse I'm gonna say service and we're
gonna look for the one named Swift and
here we have the holo world for Swift
running up on App Engine so you're able
to take the code that you want the
languages you want to write in for seven
of those we have them built in but if
there's a language that you need to use
that we don't support you can just go
into a docker container five lines in a
docker file and pretty much any language
you can actually
on top of App Engine and this is milli
what we described I can use my own
docker file I can take the existing
runtimes we have and take it out now
what's interesting is you can take those
out and actually go run them on
kubernetes or run them in GCE the code
that you build between these platforms
is entirely portable you can let us
build the container or you can build it
in your own infrastructure you can build
in Jenkins on your own CI system then do
the deployment or will do it you can
publish your container to Google
container registry and then as I
mentioned these are very portable so if
you look back at our application we did
a little bit of what I like the Cahuilla
we looked at it said it's a model if
make it micro services the guy from
Google said micro services are good but
really we didn't really do any
performance analysis to back up the fact
that we had to go do that right so we
split that we did a lot of work if I
wanted to go do that I have we've only
haven't asked the question how's my
application performing and how can I go
figure that out
so let's check out how we can go analyze
the performance of our apps in
production I'm going to go over here and
I'm hoping that some of you use that
photobooth ass because if you didn't you
didn't generate enough load and the demo
is going to go sideways and it's going
to be really bad all right we had a
couple of hits so here I'm on the App
Engine dashboard and we're taking a look
at now is a whole bunch of metrics to
help us understand how users are hitting
our app this is actually the photobooth
app that we were just using where we
took the picture and it generated the
Twitter card you can see we had a little
bit of a traffic spike and we got up to
a total of 10 requests there so 10 I'll
take it but what are some of the other
metrics that we can dig into I can take
a look at the average latency and I can
see how the latency breaks down from my
request but the 50th 95th and 99th
percentile I can dig in and take a look
at my CPU utilization and understand how
that's been acting if I go down into the
instances tab I can see the current list
of machine instances were running and I
can even get really deep detailed
information about how the autoscaler is
behaving here we can see I'm sitting at
to to see two machine type instances we
can take a look at our utilization as
that utilization dips up over the green
line you can see it's scaled up there
for a second so I can even dig deep and
understand how CP utilization leads to
me auto scaling my
location up or down so that wasn't a lot
of we didn't really have to do much
there right like I was using imagemagick
we have like ten requests at the peak
you know that's not a lot of QPS
what if we wanted to kick this off the
notch what if I didn't want to do images
you know what could I do to like take
the CPU a little bit more maybe I want
to do video so let's give that a shot
and see what it might look like so last
time we did a static screenshot this
time I'm going to go to actually don't
remember the URL the other one was card
yeah it wasn't video a gift that's what
it is we're going to generate a gift
gift appengine dot and this one instead
of just taking an image it's going to
record a video and the whole time going
to talk I'm going to dance it's going to
be awesome recording a video on stage
recording a video while recording a
video and then we're going to do is
upload that video from the browser send
it to an application that I have running
and then when it generates the card
instead of building a static image what
I wanted to do is go build something
that's live and there we go and so I'm
going to take this and post it to
Twitter oh thank you I was inspired by a
movie about wizards where everything
they read had like moving pictures on it
and I wanted that for myself so you can
go to gift-wrap engine do generate one
of these for yourself and tweet it out
if you'd like to but let's talk about
how I actually built that and why this
might put a strain on my system so to
build this I chose to use ffmpeg which
is kind of like the Swiss Army knife of
video editing and the same way that
image magic is the Swiss Army knife for
image processing but you know as you
could imagine when I started playing
around with that you know especially if
you any of you are trying it right now
ffmpeg takes you know a fair bit of CPU
cycles this is a this is video
processing it tends to be very CPU
intensive work so that leads us to trick
number seven of what you can build on
App Engine which is you can actually
because it's so CPU intensive I want to
customize the underlying hardware and
this is a new thing that you can do on
top of App Engine in GA as of this week
to do that we're taking advantage of
Google compute engines custom machine
type feature now what this lets us do is
actually size our instances
not based on a pre-canned set of machine
types besides our instance completely
tailored to our needs
so right now you know we give you a
preset version of CPU memory and disk
that seems to work for most people but
from an image proper from my video
processing application what I really
needed is I didn't need as much memory
when it came to disk I was installing
anything locally I was using Google
Google Cloud storage so I didn't mean
much disk when it came to CPU I needed a
lot of CPU if we're going to handle you
know a couple hundred people in a room
for this talk and to specify that all
you need to do is inside of that app dot
yam will file where you're supposed to
telling us the rest of how to build your
app just tell us I need a lot of CPU I
need a little bit of memory and that's
it you can customize the hardware inside
of your machine completely based on the
needs of your application so let's give
it a try
and if you want to give it we already
did this but if you want to give it a
try you can go out to gift
App Engine dot IO we can see see if we
can get it to scale up at the end or get
it to scale all the way up at the end we
can take a look at the stats used to
prime some statistics for me for the
dashboard all right so we're getting
towards the end now we've got seven
tricks our last one was customizing the
underlying hardware it was seven or
eight we got the last one to work I
called on an old devil from last year
actually to get this put together but if
you look back to our application I've
used this slide a couple times you'll
get a pretty simple app but you know
there's a pretty trivial app that we
just built right you know there are two
App Engine services one pub/sub thing in
the middle in production our apps rarely
end up actually looking like that you
know this is kind of a contrived example
a more classic example of what you're
going to go build is something that
looks like this you know we're going to
have front-end front of backends one of
the cues we're going to have AP eyesore
taking advantage of an unscalable file
storage we're going to databases or to
manage databases we're going to have
virtual machines that run that old piece
of software that we couldn't port you
know there are all kinds of different
pieces in a real production service
along with duct tape and baling wire and
love that it takes to keep it it takes
to keep it running over time so to do
this one of the best parts about App
Engine is that you have access to all of
the api's that are available inside of
Google Cloud spanner we announced cloud
machine learning the video intelligence
API pub saw bigquery vision API is a big
long list of all the different things
these are now all at your fingertips
and simple to use from within of your
App Engine application you don't just
have to use the services that come out
of the box with App Engine it's all of
GCP GCP is the new platform as a service
so to do that on nodejs all I had to do
was npm install google cloud and we had
an NPM module that had access to all
those services of course you're a Python
pip if you're in ruby gem and i kept
going with this but it was too many
slides you know it's available in all of
those seven languages that we talked
about earlier and to use this API let's
say that I wanted to do something very
simple let's say that I just wanted to
be able to look at a picture and figure
out what's in that picture you know
traditionally like one of those problems
I think it will take an army of computer
scientists eight years to solve well
with Google cloud on App Engine using
the vision API I can do it in four lines
of code four lines of all four lines of
JavaScript I can do it in four lines of
JavaScript we just bring in the library
detect the labels and then we can find
out is a dog a canine a poodle but you
don't have to take my word for it you
know we're going to try it out so with
access to these machine learning api's
all this technology that we've built up
at Google over the last you know two
decades all the intelligence all the
stuff in Google photos mail inbox you
know amazing technology not our
fingertips we can actually go off and we
could change the world if we wanted to
with this stuff I use it to build an app
about my cat so let's see what that
looks like so I'm going to go to cloud
cats
appspot.com and what I wanted to find
out is I wanted to find out if people
found doves or cats to be the cutest of
animals and to do that I decided to use
the cloud vision API so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to go off and read a
bunch of data from reddit our /aw to be
specific this is all real time you can
go and check it out if you want to I'm
going to figure out are there more
pictures of dogs or cats on the aw
subreddit so let's give it a shot
okay so we're downloading each of these
images this is a front-end process it
has a back-end communication is through
pub/sub and it's using the video api we
got our first response it looks like
we've got a cat's out to an early lead
but the dogs are catching up there are a
lot more puppies in this one than there
usually are so that's good we've got
sleepy kitty got a little bit of
duplication going on but that's okay I
think the dogs are back out to a lead we
have a you think that's a Yoda cat
that's awesome we've got Jedi cat dog in
sunglasses and this we're going to go on
for a while at the end of us it's we're
gonna be able to use the cloud vision
API to break up and split out all of
these different characteristics you know
all the chaos in these images it can
tell us dog cat neither or both cat with
pancakes
that is amazing all right and let's see
I have to have to wait until it gets to
the end a half a know if the cast of the
dogs win much anticipation all right I'm
just going to let it
and we'll come back to this in a second
so what did we learn today the big
things that I want you to come away is
I'm hoping that you came away with from
this talk that we really want you to be
able to focus on your code you know as
developers we really have to be thinking
of our customers all the time we have to
be focusing on doing what's best for
them building our applications focusing
on our business shouldn't have to focus
on infrastructure and that's one of the
goals ultimately that we have with app
engine once you'll be able to focus on
not only just on your code but any code
it shouldn't be limited to the seven
languages that we support when you be
able to bring in anything bring in your
perl bring your swift bring your elixir
whatever you need to run your
application inside of the clouds to
solve problems for your customers one
should be able to break beyond paths so
a lot of the limits that you
traditionally think of when you run into
a platform as a service offering you
shouldn't have to put up with it there
should be ways to use custom amounts of
CPU your own languages bring your own
container and lastly we want you to be
able to liberate intelligence so we have
access now to things like the speech API
the video API the the vision API you can
now use these Fulda many your
applications and use them to help solve
real problems for your customers all the
stuff that we did today as I mentioned
is up on github there's a bunch of more
information that these links you have
over here if you have questions for us
if you ever want to talk to the App
Engine team we're always available we're
always on our slack room you can go here
to GCP slack appspot.com to sign up for
that and we're happy to answer questions
for you any time and thank you